[Music]
the public are just looking at it now
and going what is the ASA it's just an
absolute nightmare you know where are we
from day to day is becoming this massive
pantomime the suffering of victim of
sexual violence and survivors was hurt
anybody who thinks I've had a facelift
are talking at the Botox
it's really wonderful and a privilege in
special I can't really believe it
because when I was a child a delay or
defeat this decision time for Theresa
May were time running out to win over a
hundred and fifty MPs as the number she
needs to win two mores a brexit vote and
quite possibly to keep her job if we
went ahead and held the vote tomorrow
the deal would be rejected we will
therefore defer the vote scheduled for
tomorrow
and not proceed to divide the house at
this time we're an extremely serious and
unprecedented situation the government
has lost control of invents and is in
complete disarray another day of brexit
humiliation for an embattled prime
minister
[Applause]
there are chaotic scenes in Parliament
as tensions boil over but the man who
called the referendum says he has no
regrets my man had promised in the
election to call a referendum and I
called the referendum obviously I'm very
concerned about what's happening today
but I do support the Prime Minister in
her efforts to try and have a close
partnership with the European Union
it's the right thing to do to resumes -
your own Europe to save the EU exit dear
Prime Minister will leap with you lead
us to push for more concessions and our
exit plan locks and the back seats but
will the UK be locked in the back stop
this is Mason's reassurances on the
Irish corner and says MPs will get a
vote on her deal before January the 21st
I have never in all those years
witnessed such an abject mess as this
Prime Minister is making of these
crucial brexit negotiation the thing
that is changing is the view of the
British people
[Applause]
nearly the pantomime season but oh yes
it has but shouldn't be easily the
theatrics to the professionals
no the public are just looking at it now
and going what is this it's just an
absolute nightmare you know where are we
from day to day is becoming this massive
pantomime which is that that's our
government that supposed to be there for
everybody and doing the best and all
they're doing is fighting amongst women
I think we have a sense of human
reservation and I think sometimes it
lightens the load a little bit but I
feel that the politicians now a lot of
them have actually distanced themselves
from the population they're soldiers
doing the work whereas Parliament was a
bit of a I think that some of them ought
to stop and I think before they actually
open their mouths they're doing their
own stage show I suppose are playing I
don't know what they're doing they
should come to the pantone with us MPs
have triggered that no confidence votes
in the Prime Minister this morning the
chair of the 1922 committee severe
radium fee has confirmed that the
contest will take place tonight Primus
is very keen that we should move rapidly
clearly wants resolution as soon as
possible I have devoted myself
unsparingly to these tasks ever since I
became Prime Minister and I stand ready
to finish the job it was not an easy
letter to write Theresa May he came in
to farm at 90 97 with me we've both been
MPs 21 years we
worked closely together effectively the
Prime Minister has been drowning
politically an angler Merkel's throne
buckets of water at these emissions
resent the entire government should
design because it's made such a mess or
breaks in the prime minister has my full
support
I think some of my colleagues who I've
have forgotten to take their meds in the
last 24 hours
will have totally lost leave lost leave
of all of their senses I just can't
understand what people are doing and why
we need to do stick with treason egg has
a plan promised is the right person to
take us forward we need to give our full
support
I hope colleagues will then get back to
delivery for the country and she can get
out here on the table for the UK is the
changing a prime minister in midstream
is not going to improve anything it will
only make things worse
this is where mrs. Mays fate will be
sealed this evening committee room 14 in
the House of Commons she's addressing
her MPs to set out exactly why she's
still the best person to lead the party
and the country when the door opens he
really had a space made for her to get
in here to squeeze through the business
the room was just so packed her allies
her critics all press together listening
to what she has to say in this speech
that will potentially make or break her
career the result of the balance held
this evening is that the parliamentary
party does
[Applause]
nearly a hundred jority that's a great
result that's really strengthen her
position and there's put in debt and
it's removed the doubt about a
leadership now III just hope that the
conservative MPs who didn't supporter
will rally around now and and will reach
a collective view let's hope all the MPs
get behind to resume and let's get the
deal signed and sealed and let's work
hard to get a good deal from the
European Union because I'm sure they
they will Bend eventually which is what
we will need I think we need stability
and we need to get on with the the new
direction for the country do you think
now certainly from a party member level
you'd like to see lime drawn we just get
over things that's what people are
telling me just get on with it Bryn's
attempt to leave the European Union has
been compared to Catalonia's efforts to
try to secede from Spain well charisma
the man who called in one catalonia's
referendum which was supposed to play
the legal boundary European democracy
must be improved because we expect not a
clear support in our fight for
independence but the clear support the
clear commitment from the European Union
institutions to our fundamental rights
which are clear violated from a state
member as a Spain and when you see how
how difficult the European Union is
making it for the UK to follow through
on its own fully legal referendum and
leave do you see similar characteristics
there from the European Union
yes in in some point of view yes of
course
as a pro European people we don't like
brexit but is also bad news not only for
UK but for European Union and no deal or
not good deal but that shows European
Union is probably a very good successful
economical project
but not a political one in political
point of view the European Union must be
improved in a very good way than these
days can explain us and we hope we hope
the both sides can be the best for
achieve good a good deal is only in our
interest in the Catalan interest to see
a European Union more committed to
fundamental values from the mental
rights and find an agreement with the
United Kingdom is also not a matter of
economics but also a democratic
democratic issue a democratic goals
this is dr. Denis mukwege a at his
hospital and his home it's a place of
healing in a region rat with
unimaginable suffering
among his duties treating women and
children who've been raped with extreme
violence and his work in the Democratic
Republic of Congo has won him the Nobel
Peace Prize how did you feel when you
heard that you had won the Nobel Prize
yeah my feeling was really that the
suffering of victim of sexual violence
and the survivors was hurt I find that
women really who came to me to seek
treatment was wrapped in with extreme
violence and I could not be indifferent
I just taken the responsibility to start
to treat them and this I didn't really
go to school to learn how to do it there
was a medical degree that taught you
what I think what I saw even for the
first time myself even if I was a
medical doctor I was so traumatized also
because it's not really something you
can then get constant to learn how to do
it I can imagine when people can shoot
in the genital of women we have to
reconstruct the vagina to reconstruct
the bladder to reconstruct the rectum
and this kind of things you don't have a
school worker knowledge I treat a mother
after I treat her girl and the
grandchildren should I stay in the
operating room just waiting women can
and be treated I just feel that to treat
the consequences was not the solution do
you live in fear because of the pressure
that is brought the pressure the
pressure is there of course and you can
see even in media what the factory news
ads are doing each week against me and
against what I am doing but
I think that this can't stop us to talk
about was what is going on in this
country and you hope that one day maybe
Zabur the coldest population can take a
more responsibility on their own destiny
he for one has taken responsibility for
the hospital and the people it serves
like this twelve-year-old girl Tina who
is deaf was raped last year and dr.
mukwege a cared for her during the
resulting pregnancy
[Music]
[Music]
you know all the Asians
his work in Bukavu has inspired the
world by serving his community with
empathy and grace
[Music]
the household name is at 20 UK top 40
albums and he could be striving to the
Christmas number 1 with his new album
walking in the midnight the Irish
singing superstar Daniel O'Donnell is
back with his first new studio album in
[Music]
its a collection of songs that I've been
gathering for a number of years a lot of
original songs by Irish writers and some
covers as well I mean down through the
years I've recorded a lot of older songs
covers of of hits from years gone by
which has worked well for me but this
album the walk in the moonlight is an
original written by a man called Pat
McLean from my own country Donegal and
I'm very happy with it and thanks to
everybody for buying it it's in the
chart so again they're there supporting
but they always do don't they I mean do
you know how many albums you have
released over the course of you well
I've recorded an album every year since
1984 sometimes two and a year and since
1988 we've had an album on the charts
and that's turned to the audience who
thought of what I do and support what
they do and in the grid I have to say I
know exactly how committed your fan base
is I used to work in a theatre back home
in Scotland called the gaiety theatre
where you played a a good few times and
I don't know that I've ever seen a
response like it from an audience the
only thing I can paid it to is you know
kids in one direction you know these
ladies were going wild for you and we're
throwing plenty of objects well the the
really have been terrific I mean I
started doing concerts here in the UK
and 1987 and we have shows in May we're
in Bournemouth and Stevenage and
Southport and Aberdeen in May and then
we do after and I
in August so people are very supportive
and it's it's it's fantastic I mean I've
been singing since 1981 and is it the
performing of the other recording the
other performer yeah I love the live
show there's nothing to compare with it
really and sometimes you get some famous
people in the audience as well don't you
Doug of course
Pope Francis well that was that was a
great thrill for me to get the
opportunity to sing in front of the of
the Pope
we are very honored on Sunrise to have a
living legend in the studio today
someone who's made people smile for more
than 50 years he's looking good on it is
that getting ready for pantomime in
Windsor and crucially supporting the
shooting star Children's Hospice with
his new charity single
[Music]
and bring the TT right isn't he
Jose it does I would off watch the video
last night I sort of fought I didn't
realize you could sing but then you back
in the day you did a single with Scylla
black didn't oh yes but then we always
used to change all the words and take
the mickey out of it and you see this
was an idea by mr. mank read the DG who
said why don't we do something
completely different you know it would
have been obvious to have done something
like boom boom shake shake the room get
people thinking and on YouTube in fact
some of the comments have been that
somebody said they've got an
impressionist who can sing and sound
like bezel brass ooh that's quite a
compliment well no one can sound quite
like you now tell us why you wanted to
support the The Children's Hospice well
it was all instigated last year by mr.
Mike Reid when we did Penta together
he's really is related to the hospice
and he helps them out a lot and
suggested that I do a little Christmas
single so I met them at the Dorchester
with Simon Cowell he's their president
okay after only an hour of being there
and then four hours later it was the
most inspirational four hours I've ever
spent with these little girls and their
little boys and the families some of
whom may not still be here this
Christmas when I thought what could I do
and Christmas single seemed to be a very
good idea and do it quite seriously make
people think and stand out from the
crowd and it's doing well in the charts
there's no change - yes a penny I was
number 15 at the weekend I was usurped
by Macmillan some the jungle he would
straight to number one
Oh Harry might get there with my we
might be there Fox factor versus the
expec to make food Oh Fox Factor winner
do you'll get the Christmas number one
slot then well it would be lovely
wouldn't it if I did get the number one
it I wasn't doing it for that reason
it's really to raise awareness of the
charity and raise a bit of money but if
I was there on Christmas Day
oh that would be absolutely what do you
put your longevity down to basil because
I mean you've been around since before
we were born
you're gonna say before time then really
funny walk with you that's why it's so
exciting to have you here in the flesh
in the studio I can't believe we have
basil the funny thing is you know I sort
of started in 1963 on the David Nixon
show and a lady called Anita Harris oh
yes and would you believe I'm currently
in pentamer I'm at the Theatre Royal
Windsor with the very same and heater
hellish Wow so amazing and then I'm
meeting children coming in with with
others and their parents saying I grew
up with you and their parents grew up
with you and last year I was at
Glastonbury and all these 20 year olds
were saying I grew up with you so bad so
what is this secret how do you keep
yourself looking so young and you work
out well anybody who thinks I've had a
facelift are talking at the Botox
everyday I just sit that work out when
I'm gonna have me breakfast and I've
seen what you've got in your sky canteen
and it's fantastic can I be really
personal just because I'm actually a big
cat lover I've got I've got my Mino he
really likes it if I do that behind his
oh that's rather nice the stars of the
hotly anticipated Mary Poppins Returns
have graced the blue carpet at Royal
Albert Hall for the film's European
premiere topping offer practically
perfect night emily Blunt's been
nominated for a Screen Actors Guild
Award for the title role also appearing
is Hamilton's star lin-manuel miranda
who plays a cockney Lamplighter
[Music]
MARY POPPINS who came back you seemed
hardly to have aged at all really
one never discusses a woman's age
Michael would have hoped I taught you
better
jack is the Lamplighter is someone full
of childhood innocence in wonder
Hamilton has none of that so I'm really
grateful he saw me for this role and if
you and your family relocated to London
for this film and tell me did that help
you nail that cockney accent yeah
absolutely you know it's funny I spent
this summer in Cardiff working on a new
series for the BBC and I have a Texas
accent in that it is harder to hold on
to a Texas accent Cardiff than the
London accent in London so it was a joy
you first began your writing career
because you said they were literally
like two for tareka rose in musicals
that was it that was it
yeah it's bernardo and it's Paul in A
Chorus Line and so I sort of started
creating my own opportunity so then to
be offered a role of this caliber with
this creative team feels like the fruit
of all that and you've made it happen
it's amazing are you looking forward to
showing you two boys
this one yeah they're gonna see it this
weekend when I get back home today or
and you know my son has seen me dance
with penguins and climb buildings and
but all on set so I can't wait to put it
all together for
to what
[Music]
that every movie you make
[Music]
remember
joy comfort human possibility and
imagination needed even in even in dark
times
so you've been off filling the
children's heads with stuff and nonsense
[Music]
to be a child it's really wonderful and
a privilege and special I can't really
believe it because when I was a child I
so much
you never think that you'll be involved
in you'll actually get to be in the
world but as a child your imagination I
just take it it loved
for the impossible
[Music]
we go
[Music]
something that we watched every
Christmas always on the television
that's in the greatest game the two
films that was never a time when I
didn't know
[Music]